c'est les folles d'une influence aux
américaines qui vit au texas et a
déboursé 23 mille euros pour cloner son
chat après sa mort il a fallu quatre ans
de tentatives infructueuses avia guen un
laboratoire américain pour obtenir cette
copie presque conforme c'est en corée du
sud en 2005 que le chien snoopy et le
premier animal domestique à être clonée
en 2018 la chanteuse barbra streisand
saute le pas en faisant planer sa
chienne samantha et elle obtient deux
chiots à noter que cette pratique est
interdite en europe
oui c'est faux mais je tenais oui ah ben
ouais alors c'est une grosse arnaque
parce que cette pauvre fille je pense
qu'elle va récupérer snoopy et en fait
elle va récupérer le jumeau de snob donc
c'est pas son chien parce que un clonage
c'est pas une réincarnation
en france à
droite j aumale droit gagnant ça
fonctionnera et non pas des animaux ton
nom j'ai peur moi j'ai peur des chats
des chiens j'ai donc vraiment pas peur
de ça des chiens sales moi je veux pas à
l'aise s'est pas rassuré même un petit
un petit chien à petit ça va mais
c'est sympa mais oui mais c'est pas que
je les aime pas c'est que j'ai peur un
accord soutient beaucoup d une dérive
super grave parce que là on bombarde
chat décédé mais bientôt ce sera des
humains brett on pourra le pourra enfin
connaître imewe imprimé en humain qui a
10 ans parce qu'il voit un enfant
qu'elle sait rien basiquement clooney
brad pitt y apporte aussi un mégot que
tenait bon terme la risée ont ressassé
n'importe quoi senna pourquoi après on
va vouloir des blessures mais sa réponse
est oui d'une part aussi mais comment on
fait pour monter une société de clonage
pour 23000 euros
moi je lui rends maintenant chaque comme
ça
mais ces pages
richard si j'arrive à trouver dix chats
dans la
niche à 230 mais là tu as des beaux
projets toi mais toujours mal honnête
si je me tirais